we're going to talk about cyber security
today because of what happened last week
to twitter
a 30 billion company ran by jack dorsey
330 million users
millions of people use it on a daily
basis somebody was able to hack their
system and specifically
to the following accounts president
barack obama joe biden
kim kardashian elon musk apple i can
give you a ton of names
they hacked into the account and here's
what the tweet said i am
giving back to my community due to covet
19.
all bitcoin sent to my address below
will be sent back doubled
if you send a thousand dollars a bitcoin
i will send back two thousand dollars
with a link going on and says i'm only
doing this for the next 30 minutes
a bunch of people fell for it so here's
the question if twitter
a 30 billion dollar company ran by jack
dorsey
330 million users can be hacked
can you get hacked and somebody takes
away your passwords your checking
account
your method of getting into all your
social media send emails can somebody do
that and can you find a way to protect
yourself
against any of that happening sure you
can we're going to talk about that today
in today's video we're going to talk
about
cyber security stats biggest data
breaches
of the 21st century method of hacking
how people hack into accounts and last
but not least
solution how you can protect yourself
[Music]
so brace yourself because some of these
stats are going to shock you let's get
right into it number one
hackers attack different accounts every
39 seconds that means every 39 seconds
someone's being hacked
number two since covet 19 fbi reported a
300 percent increase
on reported cyber crimes next 43 percent
of cyber attacks
target small businesses average global
cost for breach
is now 3.9 million dollars
across the board for small business
owners 95 percent of breached records
come from three industries government
retail technology in retail they're
focused on credit cards
technology they want passwords which
gets into banking and obviously
government and social security a bunch
of different records
approximately watch this number here
approximately
six trillion dollars is expected to be
spent globally
on cyber security by 2021. i didn't say
1 trillion
6 trillion unfilled cyber security jobs
worldwide will reach
4 million by 2021 by the way average
cyber security engineer salary a 140 000
year income
more than 77 of organizations do not
have any cyber security incident
response plan
77 total cost for cyber crimes worldwide
added up to over a trillion
dollars average time to identify a
breach in 2019 was 206 days
according to ibm only five percent of
company folders
are properly protected on average let me
say that one more time
only five percent of all company folders
are protected that's five percent only
estimated number of passwords
used by humans and machines worldwide is
officially over 300 billion
passwords we got seven billion people
living worldwide
300 billion passwords are being used
56 percent of americans don't know what
to do once there's an event of a data
breach
34 percent of data breaches involve
internal actions
1 in 36 cell phones have high risk apps
installed and last but not least
financial services
industry takes in highest cost from
cyber crime
at an average of 18.3 million dollars
per
company surveyed think about that 18.3
million dollars
so i'm curious after seeing these stats
and hearing me say it to you what do you
think about
what what does it make you feel like
because i can tell you for me at
two and a half years ago when i'm at an
insurance conference hearing stats like
this i sat there and i said let me get
this straight
i run a business multiple i got
investments i got companies i got family
i got kids i got
all of these different things how am i
protecting myself so when we came back
two and a half years ago till today
i've spent around two million dollars on
cyber security different
analysts we've hired full-time
technology software constantly we're
putting money into it now you may be
watching the same path
i don't have that kind of money i don't
have that kind of a size of a business
but i'd like to find a way to protect
myself
that's why this video is sponsored by
expressvpn if you follow valuetainment
you know we don't say yes to all
sponsors but we decided to say yes to
expressvpn because we like what they do
they're ranked number one by cnet
and wired for what they do which is a
virtual private
network express vpn vpn is a virtual
private network here's how it works
think about it if you're on your
internet service provider you're
searching
whatever website you're on your internet
service provider can
legally in u.s sell all your data they
can sell it and it's not illegal
if you don't have something like
expressvpn they can do that once you
have it
it's protected probably the best analogy
i can give you is the following thing
think about using the internet and you
put a condom on
i know it's a weird analogy but no one
can get in
to see what you got going on because
you're officially protected so
passwords your ip addresses you go to
any of that stuff
you're fully protected if you have
expressvpn a lot of times people say
well i'll go incognito and i'll go
private and i can
delete my cookie in my history they can
still track all of that and the good
news is that expressvpn is in 90 plus
different countries and you can use
expressvpn to protect your phone
pc tv video game any of that stuff so
if you want to get your online activity
protected
go to my exclusive link it's
expressvpn.com
forward slash pbd vpn you see it on the
screen as well we're gonna put the link
below as well
to get yourself started you may not be
able to spend the kind of money we've
spent to protect our company
but you can definitely get yourself
started with something simple as
expressvpn so having said that
let's get into the biggest data breaches
of 21st century the first one is yahoo
so
three billion user accounts in 2014 and
were breached this is names email
passwords date of birth
and security questions that's yahoo by
the way that's the biggest of all time
three billion by the way they took two
three years to tell the world that they
were preached
with three billion accounts you got cena
weeble which is kind of like the twitter
of china 538 million accounts
were hacked in march of 2020. marriott
500 million customers that's contact
passport number once again your passport
information
100 million credit card info that's to
come out and tell people
that this really took place adult friend
finder that's
412.2 million accounts penthouse.com
coms.com icoms.comscriptshow.com
imagine all of that data that they're
going out there breaching right
myspace 360 million accounts in 2013
which is pretty funny here
to see the myspace link with linkedin
you'll be surprised what the hacker
asked in return to release all that
information back
netease 235 million user accounts this
is an email this was in october of 2015.
zynga 218 million user accounts this is
gaming
linkedin 165 million user accounts that
was in 2016. by the way watch this
the same person that hacked myspace is
the same person that hacked
linkedin you know what all this kid
wanted he just wanted five bitcoins
at the times it was worth two thousand
dollars think about it very soon
i have these things i give it back to
just give me five bitcoins right
some simple kid that's hacking an
account dubsmash 162 million user
accounts adobe big company
153 million user records my
fitness pal that's under armour's app
150 million user accounts
equifax 147.9 million ebay 145 million
and last but not least ashley madison
which was 32 million
accounts when that came out it was
mayhem everybody was wondering if their
name is going to be on the list or not
so now
all of these companies are big companies
these are not small companies
but there are different methods of
hacking which i'm going to talk to you
about
and many of the methods of hacking you
can protect yourself about but sometimes
if you're not
aware you get caught because you were
not fully prepared on what could
potentially happen
these companies this typically happens
because
an employee didn't pay attention to what
they were doing and then boom they got
caught that's how it happens
it's not like these companies don't have
the proper protection somebody screwed
up now watch this
methods of hacking number one a virus a
trojan
this is a virus within something you
download or install
the moment you do it virus spreads into
your computer and there's many things it
can do
stop your computer take all the
passwords have access to what you're
doing there's many methods to it number
two is phishing
phishing is replicate website to enter
login or password for example
you'll get an email saying
congratulations we found out you're a
celebrity you're officially getting
verified on instagram oh my gosh i'm
getting verified on instagram
you log in you put in your username you
get your password
then a 20-minute study guide sends you
an email saying wait a minute we just
got into your email account you give me
a thousand dollars
i'll release your instagram you know how
i know this happens it's happened to us
before four years ago three years ago
when this happened to us
it happens to everybody the best way to
figure out for phishing
is always see where the email is coming
from so if it comes from gmail
it's not instagram if it's from whatever
like john doe at
instagramxyz.com it's not instagram so
it's always good to click on the email
to find out who's sending it to you
number three
eavesdropping this one is epic because
they monitor what you're doing but you
don't even know they're in your system
so they get into your system you're
going on the website there's no virus
the virus is i watch everything you're
doing that's eavesdropping
that's a method of hacking next one is a
fake web
fake web has fake wi-fi to get access to
your data it's very obvious what that is
next one is waterhole attacks which
means it's similar to a fake web
but they're doing it in a location with
a lot of traffic coming in so imagine a
busy starbucks imagine a
busy bookstore a busy mall where a lot
of people are tapping into that wi-fi
and i can go and get access to a lot of
different people's accounts and activity
next one is ddosing which is denial of
service so flooding
with traffic to crash your site it's not
really something that they want to get
anything from you
it's more to embarrass you let me crash
the pentagon website let me crash the
facebook website to embarrass them and
humiliate them
it's a it's a different method of doing
what they do okay keylogger is very
simple this is malware that tracks your
keypad so whatever you're typing
whatever email you're sending whatever
thing you're saying with the keypad
they're able to see it next
social engineering this is fake phone
calls it's also happening on social
media whether it's through skype
this is when you get somebody calling
you and they get you to feel comfortable
whether they're representing the irs
whether they're representing
you you have a lawsuit against you have
disciplines you feel guilty oh my gosh i
mean what's your social security number
is it this
and you give all your data boom they're
already in and then you're in trouble
they're able to use that stuff
uh against you next one is bait and
switch which is fake
ads that takes you to a different place
that leads to a virus that's what bait
and switch is then it's cookie theft
which is taking your cookies
off your computer which leads to getting
access to your passports and many other
things so remember
these are things that are happening no
matter how much you spend
if you don't pay attention to this stuff
it can get you in trouble so what's the
solution number one
everything i talked about today will
give you a pdf at the end for you to
download
where you can teach your employees your
family everybody either have them watch
this video which i highly recommend your
family your kids your spouse your
employees
watching this video to know exactly what
the potential ways of getting actors
but teach them these stats our business
analysts they send stats mario on a
weekly basis what is it every single
week we get stats that come out that
tell us everything about cyber security
so our employees are always watching out
for it number two
swot analysis with your team and your
family what is swot analysis
what are our strengths when it comes
down to uh cyber security
what are our weaknesses what
opportunities do we have what are some
threats
bring in your team bring in your
employees bring in your family and talk
about swot analysis
when you do swot analysis with your
family you realize you're just giving
your ipad to your kids you don't even
know what they're doing
and some of the stuff they're doing
you're not watching like oh here you go
get on the ipad and
be distracted for 30 minutes they may
have logged into your credit card
account that's right there they're not
really
looking at the stuff so swot analysis
with your family and your business
number three
change passwords don't use your pet's
name and your password and your pet's
got its own instagram account linked
back to you
you know and it's oh good this is the
password oh what an easy guy thank you
so much for making your password so easy
change your password make it something
that makes no sense put a sentence
that is a long sentence with 30 letters
no one can find that and then find some
numbers that are not
necessarily your date of birth number
four straighten your home network call
your
service provider and ask them what do i
need to do to make it stronger maybe a
little bit more expensive but it's a lot
cheaper than you getting hacked number
five
hire an analyst to do an audit so for
example say you're a small business with
five employees
you may not have a lot of money to spend
the kind of money i'm talking about but
maybe you can afford three thousand
dollars five thousand dollars ten
thousand dollars
have somebody come in and say can you
audit all of my stuff that i have in
place
and use a credible company they'll come
and they'll look at your week here your
week here your week they're your week
that you agree
i can help you with this we can clean
this up and they'll help you spend three
four five thousand dollars ten thousand
dollars
to make you feel comfortable what you
got going on number six is using
certain apps or technology that stores
all your passwords there's a lot of
credible ones you can go look them up
for yourself
an example of a company is keepass k-e-e
pass these are some of the softwares and
technologies that store 40 50
passwords of you know a lot of time you
got seven different passwords i forgot
the password to this
i forgot the password today but you save
save it in a place that's not saved
then somebody can see it that somebody
can get access to the next you know
they're fishing into your accounts and
money's leaving because you didn't
protect yourself
you can use different apps to help you
with that number seven is keep
your eyes on your kids technology
go home and talk to your dad what do you
use grandpa what do you use
mom husband wife kids everybody
and last but not least if you are
attacked
cyber attack whatever happens to you
somebody is using your technology
contact local authorities whether it's
the cops the ftc federal trade
commission
and fbi i've dealt with all three
organizations
and i highly recommend you going
straight to the reason why many times
people don't
is for the following reason many times
they don't because a person comes back
and says listen bro
listen dude you pay me 500 i'll give the
password back to you and people give it
back
and it's over with that person needs to
be reported so they can't do that to the
next person and the next person and the
next person
so there are fewer victims but many
times people don't report them i'm
recommending you
report them to ftcf behind the cops so
they don't do it to the next person
because it continuously
keeps happening so final thoughts i've
got three things for you number one i
promise you pdf if you text
if you text cyber to
one three 310-340-1132 once again cyber
text the word cyber to three one zero
three four zero one one three two we
will text you back a pdf of this so you
can share with your employees your
family your staff
and talk about it number two is
expressvpn if you haven't yet gone to
make sure you go to the link below
and sign up if you sign up today for
12-month package we'll give three months
free because you're going through uh
our link that we have in place again you
sign up for 12-month package you got
three months free
get your expressvpn last but not least
if you watch this video one of the
reasons why
i interview a lot of random characters
because i'm trying to see
how people try to beat the system so i
can protect myself
the one person i sat with he was on the
secret service best list america's most
wanted list on every single list
and then eventually got arrested did
nearly 12 years of jail time
because he conned the bank away from 40
million dollars in the most creative
ways if you've never watched this
interview i highly recommend you watch
it
to know how this is happening all over
the place and you have to think
how they think so you can protect
yourself against any of these things
happening to you and your family so if
you've never watched my interview
with matthew cox click on the link over
here to watch it and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
thanks for watching everybody take care
bye
[Music]
you